Star Trek fait partie de ma vie
depuis que je suis toute petite mon père
est vraiment celui qui m'a fait découvrir Star
Trek il m'a juste fallu un épisode pour
tomber amoureux de cet autre monde que je
ne comprenais pas mais que je ressentais  comme je
pouvais comprendre, j'étais toujours très
curieux pour les personnages de l'histoire
comme vous vous êtes toujours senti émotionnellement
connecté aux personnages et quoi
qu'ils traversent, c'est
quelque chose qui fait partie de moi depuis
mon enfance, ça ne m'a jamais quitté donc
c'était  ce n'est pas comme faire une chanson pour n'importe quel film au
hasard qu'ils aiment Star Trek c'était
automatique je ferais n'importe quoi en termes
de musique c'est tellement important non seulement en
tant que fan en tant que musicien parce que Star Trek
est tellement important à travers le monde  cette
chanson devait être grande et percutante
très émotionnelle dramatique et obsédante
en même temps
je ne pouvais pas y croire j'étais très très
honorée de faire partie de ce film kala
Bhairava étouffante Pasquale
ma Chandi elle rencontre aujourd'hui une politique de
grave danger  pour convenir oh je vois la
caution totale irriguée le lon vous obtenir si
je suis Oh
ils supposeraient qu'ils vont typiquement
Kasasa grimace canario prudence si vous
Jesse Katsopolis sur Demonica passion
Misuzu Emma Daniel Pearl
apakah capitaine de Visser octopus